we're in bro gentlemen we're live okay
so episode 126 today folks we got a lot
to cover a lot's been going on and we
have jason
miller here with us who was a
former senior trump advisor i believe on
the 2016 campaign as well as you did
some work on a 2020 impeachment that you
were working with with trump so before
we get started thank you for being out
here if you don't mind taking a moment
introducing yourself yeah thank you very
much uh for those who have not had the
chance to meet before their new audience
i'm currently the ceo of getter which is
the fastest growing social media
platform in history fastest ever to 1
million 2 million 3 million for now
we're almost up to 5 million people
since launching last july very excited
what i do before that traditional uh
republican campaigns i was a senior
advisor for president trump in 2020 and
2016. quarterbacked his second
impeachment effort the one in february
after he had already left office
but now i'm fully vested in the free
speech movement trying to make the
social media app go and i think five
million in after seven months is a
pretty good start i don't think it's a
bad start so five fastest anyone's ever
done to 5 million correct facebook took
about 10 months to get to a million
twitter took a couple years now in
fairness a little bit of a different
time smartphones are a bit different but
it just shows you the scale and how
quickly it's moving i think it's because
we're at the convergence of what's hot
politically but also what's hot with the
economy jason didn't you get like a
million on day one or week one something
like that what how did you guys do on uh
uh uh how long did it take to get to a
million three days three days two
million three days was that because of
uh joe rogan or that that had nothing to
do that was so joe came along six months
later although so we're a million in
three days a million and a half in about
10 days
we're 3 million people at the end of
this last year end of 2021
after joe rogan and tucker carlson dr
robert malone some other folks we grew
by 50 percent by a million and a half
users just in the month of january of
this year so we're off to a great start
and it's the surge is real so go ahead
do you think that's a function of you
know economic supply and demand there's
a major demand for a free speech
platform is there something specific
about getter that people said i gotta
get on that specific platform or was it
just sort of a sign of the times where
it's like look clearly the big tech
overlords are sort of limiting and
shadow banning and hey here's a cool new
platform i can check out what's the
unique uh
both and the reason why i say that is i
always kind of use the analogy to
channel my inner george bailey the every
time twitter facebook or youtube kicks
someone off of their platform another
getter angel gets its wings and so it
might be terrible for democracy but when
they kick people off they look and say
you know what what else is there they
see getter and they want to come on
board but part of the reason is and you
know patrick you hit on this in a really
great segment about a year ago where he
said i'm tired of republicans whining
and saying uh you know big tech you're
bad but they're not doing anything about
it i've heard that and i said you know
what i am going to do it i'm going to
put some money behind it i'm going to go
build a real platform here's the one
dynamic i would have added to your um
very eloquent
going off of a year ago
people have come up with alternative
platforms before but the user interface
hasn't been that good the
functionalities look clunky kind of
junior varsity or b team nobody looks
and says hey twitter your functionality
is poor your user experience is poor i
want to go to some other platform they
say i'm tired of the political
discrimination i want to move
when you launch a new platform you have
to be as good if not better as the big
tech platforms if you want users to stay
even if people are turned off
ideologically by what twitter's doing it
has to be a top notch product and that's
what we've set out to do with getter so
first of all i applaud you for doing
that because i think
uh uh
you know the fact that somebody is
saying let me go out there and do this
everybody's talking let me do something
about it and uh create another
alternative for them so and i think in
today's uh climate
the current ceo of twitter probably
helps you more than dorsey does because
he seems to be more about
what what account guy canceled yesterday
000 followers or two days ago just
because they took a screenshot of other
people's tweets and they they shut them
down yeah so for anyone who is watching
listening there's an account called
defiant ls defiant and then a capital l
apostrophe s this is a great account
where all they do is say here's a tweet
from yeah defiant else oh they're back
uh they're back now they're phenomenal
and they're also on twitter just for
anyone watching define l's is on getter
which is great so they're never canceled
there that's crazy because they were at
3 35 two days ago they're at 5 10 now so
this cancellation got more eyeballs so
that went to your point also from your
segment from a year ago where you said
do you just elevate people off of some
of these cancellations which the answer
is yes i mean take a look at
look at nicki minaj for example or kyrie
irving not two people who'd say have
traditional um bases of support saying
the right of center type space but now
that there were efforts to try to cancel
them uh because of their positions on uh
kovidvac's treatments things like that
now they've become almost pop culture
heroes and sometimes they don't even
have to be someone who's uh take a look
at enos canter freedom who was with the
boston celtics and then was just
released by the rockets and what pretty
clearly is retaliatory pushback because
he's been going off on the nba in china
i know we'll get into china a little bit
more later he's now a hero to people all
over the world because he's standing up
to the ccp so some of these efforts to
cancel people but i want to go stick on
the define ls for one moment just to
tell you how the idiocy of what's going
on here all this account does i
shouldn't say all because that discounts
it but what they do is they take an old
tweet in a current tweet and it's just
basically the person taking a loss
here's where they've contradicted
themselves and some of these things that
they find are so damning like you don't
know whether to laugh or to cry there's
something these are saying it's
contradictory
but all it does is post what someone
said before and what they're saying now
just to absolutely thunder these people
and they got taken down literally for
just posting um uh just taking
screenshots from twitter yeah so why do
you think that is that that when you try
to cancel somebody or you basically you
know expose the hypocrisy they only come
back stronger what is that okay so first
of all let's let's talk whether the
strategy works or not i think it does
work somewhat okay
uh uh yiannopoulos what was it what was
his name something you know police milo
yiannopoulos right you remember when he
was milo milo yiannopoulos he used to be
everywhere right i mean everywhere you
saw him 18 million views 11 yeah
conservatives and he would talk he
was a he was a troll he was like in the
political side he would be the jake paul
so and and he was going to eventually
boom he got cancelled all this other
stuff when's the last time you heard
about him it's got to be six years maybe
five years four years it's been a minute
right since you've heard his name so it
does work with certain people right now
in in regards to silencing somebody who
has a message that makes sense and
they're talking truth all you're doing
is you're going to elevate that person
period it's just not going to work for a
couple of different reasons number one
that philosophy works if i'm living in
iran
that philosophy silence
of course it's very it's a very uh that
philosophy works if you're living in
china that philosophy works if you're
living in
you know north korea that philosophy
doesn't work in america still today it
doesn't work still today because
capitalism allows you to go compete
against those guys but i got a question
for him on getter so a few things on
getter number one what i want to know
from the business standpoint number one
is
uh backing who's backing you up and how
much money you guys got in the bank
number two is your servers who who's
your servers at aws who are you guys
with and number three is uh which app
are you on can i get it on ios can i get
it on droid if you can address those
three things so funding hosting and apps
yeah so taking those in reverse order so
we're on all the apps you can get on the
the apple store and get it on google
play fantastic you can get it anywhere
and this is critical for the following
reason if we're going to have
alternative platforms that can actually
challenge big tech you have to be able
to scale uh from those who kind of rolls
into the business side if you're simply
a web-based platform okay no one's going
to use it i can tell you that for getter
of our people access it by app and
everyone's on their mobile that's what
they're doing yes they're 13 who uh who
are web only and that's primarily in a
couple countries where uh they're just
they're different things they're doing
so they got to do it by by desktop but
so 87 so you have to be on the app
stores i mean you just if you want to
scale you can be much more limited much
more narrow but you're never going to
become the the challenger
with regard to on the uh the
monetization front and kind of where we
are um so we're going to start our uh
online appreciation and tipping for
content creators in april that's coming
up in about two months here uh tipping
like a patreon type of deal where i can
tip or more like a super chat type of uh
more like a patreon except the
difference is worse we have apple that's
been taking 35 rips for in-app purchases
that was obviously the fortnight debate
with epic
rumble has said uh that they come in at
15 for a lot of these we're gonna drop
it down and do something like in the
five to seven and a half percent range
so then as people come over and say wait
a minute i can host my show or do things
on getter and keep much more of that
money so that's that's the
chronologically that's the first thing
coming up we'll also start advertising
in q2 what's going to be a little bit
different about advertising is we have
said that we will never sell or share
any of your user data so we're going to
build out we're going to do two things
one build out in um
in platform uh advertising team
so when outside advertisers say they
want to advertise with us we give them
the specs and the demos and who they'll
go to but that data never goes to them
they're never any third parties who have
access to the data you essentially send
us the creative and the messaging that
we go and do the placement so you're
never if you sign up for getter you'll
never find out that you're getting say
text messages about buy this wine or you
know or buy this real estate or never
get emails saying here's you know fat
loss supplements or something like that
um so you'll never get any of that but
where it really gets exciting or where
it starts to grow is we're gonna launch
a two-coin crypto ecosystem payment
platform in july i'm just a little bit
ambitious right it's not quite blue
origin of going to the moon but it's
getting close uh and so that's uh so
where we're going with that that's again
i think open the doors and expose a
whole new uh essentially community not
just in the us but globally to the
benefits of the digital economy to
crypto for the opportunities
stable coin in a fluctuating coin
i think that facebook i don't think the
real reason why they pulled back on dm
was because of the regulatory challenges
with uh the stable coin i think it was
more the fact they realized that their
brand is so tarnished that they were
never going to be able to scale and grow
that because people just don't want to
give them any more data i'm sorry if
that's a little too nerdy or do you
think about the facebook crypto platform
that they were building yeah
they had libra and then then dm was kind
of their diem
was their second effort they largely
abandoned it and scrapped it but there
is a very clear yeah you don't really
hear much about that they were they had
a big launch with that and then
and there is a pathway in a platform to
do on the regulatory side because when
you tie something to the us dollar you
go from basically on a fluctuating coin
there's like wild wild west no
regulation virtually you go to a stable
coin and then you have all the
regulation in the world that's why it's
a little bit of a challenge but i think
we have a good format and structure to
go and do it
so this is kind of the cool thing right
now we're the competitor to say twitter
and facebook smaller but growing i mean
hey twitter stock is down 50 since we
launched last july so i'm just saying
yeah coincidences um facebook's had to
go and rename their their company not
all entirely because of us but a lot of
the tech stock has done though modifies
down uh a lot of the tech stops down but
they they certainly haven't held
themselves so right now largely twitter
and facebook competitor we just launched
yesterday the beta version of vision
which is our short video clip format
competitor to tick tock and instagram
reels that's so much of what everyone in
the 18 to 34. so you have that that yeah
the beta uh version beta testing so
verified users uh so a few thousand have
that right now they'll open up everyone
say four to six weeks i'd say just as we
scale up
but then as we launch the getter pay
which will be again that two coin crypto
ecosystem of the payment platform then
we become a marketplace competitor to
apple pay alipay wechat pay um plus also
think paypal american express visa a
number of these others so where we're
going with this platform it's the
all-in-one free speech platform where
your freedom of speech expression and
controlling your own financial destiny
is where we want to go so somebody just
put a super chat and they said what
happened to nick fuentes
yeah no uh nick fuentes uh was a user
who um we removed from the platform and
he was inviting people to uh be a part
of his
be a part of a group that i think is
pretty clearly uh uh racist and doesn't
fit with um within our terms of service
and look uh i'm we're you're never gonna
get everything perfect you're gonna have
people who are critics from different
sides but i'm not going to allow
getter to become the okay cupid of the
white nationalist set i'm just not what
what did nico fuentes say what group was
it uh so the gripers
okay i got it so nick if you want to
pull up his wikipedia nick joseph
fuentes is in
american far right and white nationals
political commentator live streaming the
anti-defamation league has described
fuentes as a white supremacist a former
youtuber his channel was permanently
suspended in february 2024 violating
youtube
hate speech
got it so it's not like you kicked off
fuentes has feuded with turning point
usa and it's founder charlie kirk for
supporting
views that fuentes believes to be
insufficiently conservative in october
tonight follows when uh gripers began
heckling turning point culture war tour
including a speaking event for donald
trump jr okay got it so
it's not like you kicked off a liberal
you kicked off somebody that would be
a far right person they kicked off a
ghetto look and it's i don't even think
it's a an idiot ideological thing i mean
i think when you're but it is though
because twitter you know most people
would say a lot of people that twitter
kicks off are people that are on the
right not necessarily a lot of people on
the left that's why but i think there's
i think there's a difference between
someone who is actively preaching or
recruiting for white nationalism versus
say a political ideology in my opinion
uh it might be
arguing over semantics on this one so
maybe i'm look at looking at it too
narrowly um but again a getter is a
platform where we do have uh terms of
service that are pretty clearly stated
uh we don't put up we don't have any
tolerance for racial religious epithets
uh we don't have pornography there's
plenty of places to get porn we
twitter's got a lot of points on twitter
skyline twitter's got a lot of
pornography
yesterday twitter allows you to go oh
porn okay
and you know what porn is porn is like
pornhub like yeah we can we can check it
out
how do you with that being said how do
you balance
hate speech
and freedom of speech where does the
line that's a good question because it's
leading me to the next question okay so
a really good question and again we
think what we've found with getter is
the sweet spot of the bat where we allow
people to express themselves politically
where they know that they'll never be
censored algorithmed d platform shadow
band any of that nonsense for expressing
their political beliefs whether you're
on the left or the right where
some people join the platform aren't
even that into politics maybe they just
don't like big tech or they're
inherently distrustful of it and they
want to they want to try a new platform
so our
typically in most western countries your
free speech rights extend right up to
the point where you start to infringe on
someone else's rights obviously things
such as doxing which we had to go and
suspend a very popular account for
doxing just the other day they put up
some someone's address and we had to go
and take that down that's not something
we put up with what was this term
dachshund doxxing is when you go and put
out say publicly identifiable or
publicly sensitive information so you
can't post somebody say home address and
say hey we dislike this person here's
their home address like that's that's
that's what you'd call doxing or here's
someone's credit card number or hear
someone's social security number that's
the kind of thing that's doxxing or the
other thing too if someone's outright
pushing for illegal behavior or
threatening self-harm um you know for
example if someone said uh hey go out
there and if you cut your left arm off
you can care covet okay that would be
the type of thing where that would be
something that would
potentially lead to lead to self-harm
the but your point out that you bring up
is there's always going to be that rub
between
a free speech paris who says any
restriction wait a minute are you being
hypocritical or people are saying we
want to make sure we keep the platform
safe and again we're never going to get
it right 100 of the time but our only
ideological driver is the fact that we
want to make sure that people
we support free speech and that we
oppose cancel culture so there's no
political discrimination that goes into
it like the big tech platforms where
they pick winners and losers based on
whether they agree with you well what
what did nick say that got him kicked
off what was specifically what was it
what was the message he sent uh he
posted a message that was uh effectively
recruiting people or trying to identify
with uh trying to organize uh who are
additional grapers that were on the
platform what's wrong with that
because then you're inviting uh then
that's trying to organize people who are
white nationalist group uh that we think
is uh doesn't fit with our terms of
service
okay so so
so then
so okay so you got to realize i don't
agree with what he agrees with though
the part i'm thinking about is if your
position is free thinkers
you're pushing that off then somebody
may say well there is criterias to it so
yeah and and one thing just to just be
clear here
there are uh there are plenty of places
where he can go in and preach white
nationalism and if you want to go and
preach white nationalism then you can go
to a different platform it's your choice
as a consumer we believe that our
community does not want to see that we
believe that if we're going to scale if
we're going to be a true competitor to
big tech these are the parameters that
we're going to keep people safe within
this and hey some people are going to
agree with it some people aren't but
what we're providing is so much
different and so much better than any of
the big technologies
fully free thinker though then it's not
fully free thinker because you're not
allowing me to think for myself that i
disagree with the guy
it is free thinking to a limit because
let me explain what i mean by in every
platform every platform is and that's
leading me to so for example i like
interviewing communists genuinely one of
my favorite interviews when i have a guy
that i'm sitting with that's a communist
i enjoyed that interview i know it
sounds weird and i've not done one not
two not three
any major name that's a communist i want
to sit and cure the only reason they're
not i haven't interviewed them is
because they've said no not because i
haven't invited them i enjoy talking to
them because i want to know
what makes you think the way you do and
i let the audience say
screw pat i don't agree with them that
was unfair or you know what i don't
agree with the other guy i agree with
pat great but they get to make a
decision for themselves
the part i think about what what gives
us a lot of confidence in america
what what gives you and i a lot of
confidence to live in america it's a
piece of paper right what is that piece
piece of paper called
the constitution right
and why is it so powerful because i
can't just erase it and say ah you know
what yeah
i don't know you know i don't know about
this part the constitution is here's
what the founding fathers founded this
country on right i think
for a you're a small virtual government
right now
well you got five million people living
there you're a small state essentially
if you think about it you're what's a
state with five million people idaho i
don't know the number but 5 million is a
you're a state right essentially or
you're a small country okay
that's out there but 5 million is 5
million and you are a virtual government
essentially you are a virtual nation
essentially so is twitter so is facebook
so it's youtube that's what you're
building
i think the right way to do it it's just
my feedback you have to you can take it
you cannot take it i just give them the
feedback
is to put a constitution out there
saying
these are the things that will never be
changed
and here's what we're putting on paper
so i go to the website and say this is
getter's constitution
this is what we'll tolerate this is what
we won't tolerate so i had a meeting at
uh jekyll island and i pulled my guys
aside and i took them out there and i'm
showing them rockefeller's house and i'm
showing them all these guys so it's a
very good experience if you've been to
jekyll island and in the room where the
federal you know the whole the federal
reserve got started with the whole
meetings and all that stuff in 1906 or
when when it became official we're in
the room we're having all these
conversations they're sensitive historic
and i said i want us to write out our
constitution of i we never okay so
i
dot will dot we had 13 i's we have 13
we's we have 13 nevers
so the i is i will set the best example
as a leader i that are his eyes right
the we was we collectively
we'll do x y z there never was never
will we compromise dot dot dot never
will we accept dot dot dot never will we
do the reason why i share that with our
field force is because
if somebody sees that and they say yeah
i don't like it they leave
but if somebody sees that and they say
oh my god this is home i'm here to stay
and not only am i here to stay
i'm gonna tell the world about the i we
never right i'm gonna go tell the world
about this whole thing
i think the right virtual government to
do it the right way
is to create a constitution that they
themselves will be held accountable
if they cross the line with that
constitution i may be wrong but i think
it's very important for the user to have
trust with you
i i completely agree and i think that to
that point uh so we we have our terms of
service which largely i mean it's a
contract it's the one thing that people
sign or that they check off when they
join anything whether it's
you know twitter or facebook yeah but
nobody reads terms i was about to say
that but so zero so
to that point that's obviously very
legalistic and very and the reason why
it reads legalistic is because it's your
contract
so we're actually we just hired a brand
new uh director of moderation who's
going through and actually putting
together the formal community guidelines
that'll have very specifics of
rules of the road essentially
i think that'll probably take it's
written now but we're just going through
some some refinement a couple few weeks
we'll have that posted so to your point
that will then be our constitution that
we post with more granular more kind of
real world details of kind of the the
do's and don'ts of the platform so
people fully understand it and like i
said look we're not going to get
everything right every time now we're
going to continue to grow their
different dynamics different situations
that come up and i spent i knew i was
going to spend a lot of time on
moderation when i i took on this
challenge especially after the d
platforming of january 6 and everything
i didn't maybe you know i was going to
spend quite this much time on moderation
and keep in mind right now we're largely
talking about the u.s
i'm dealing with on the global level so
then i'm dealing with ofcom with regard
to the uk i'm dealing with the german
law enforcement i'm dealing with people
in all around the world and look getter
is and one of the kind of the unique
things about it we're only 50 u.s and
prior to the rogan explosion
rogan and tucker coming on board we're
only 37 percent u.s i made it i made the
commitment when we launched this thing
this could be a global platform not just
because of where i wanted to go for
scale but also to make sure it wasn't an
american echo chamber and so brazil is
about 15 percent brazil second
brazil second who's third uh so uk is
third and just below 10. germany is
right behind them and france is right
behind them and then japan is uh then
japan and canada are like number six and
seven uh and so we've so the countries
where we have teams where we're out
working obviously the us brazil uk
france germany and then i just expanded
this quarter uh for japan india and
colombia and so those are kind of our
our big targets i think india is good
for you uh i think india is good for you
because there's a lot of free thinkers
in india and their enemy is also the
same enemy which is the china they're
not a fan of china they banned a hundred
apps in china so and so to that point
it's almost like we synced up beforehand
the drivers will be found in a lot of
our international markets where we're
targeting obviously you can get us
globally unless the government's
blocking it actually literally the day
we kicked off i think we had ten or
twenty thousand people sign up for
venezuela and then after that first day
going silent yeah they just like you
know no one else is getting it but what
we found is proximity to communism and
socialism is a huge driver so for
example people in colombia and brazil
where you're seeing all the people
fleeing from venezuela are massive
drivers south florida where you have
such a big cuban american community
massive getter user base people who are
concerned about india as you said um
also elections that are coming up in
countries where there are elections in
2022 you see a lot more political
activity people are kind of supercharged
and paying attention to it and then of
course the big one is where you have
both big tech and governments who are
coming in trying to silence people and
there's a huge difference i mean you
take a look at colombia which literally
has a no censorship clause in their own
concert constitution or it's essentially
an amendment that they had colombia
colombia brazil doesn't have their
version of a u.s first first amendment
they do not have any aspect of free
speech which kind of blew my mind this
is a major democracy uh you know
certainly in south america a big power
with a supermarket to the world when it
comes to beef markets and other things
you have the
single biggest japanese community
outside of japan and they don't have
that in fact i met the deputy carol de
tony who's writing their version of the
first amendment and i was like wait a
minute you guys don't have that she goes
nowhere in our constitution doesn't
protect it we take for granted
our first amendment rights ability to
express ourselves but obviously look at
your background where you grew up no
questions
i mean people get get killed for you
know being on the wrong side of the
street uh it's you know pretty nutty but
anyways let's start the hockey so so i'm
going to go through a couple things here
so i looked up parlor i'm looking at
parlor's data parlor got started
september of 2018.
they grew from whatever they had to 20
million users and right now they got
maybe half a million to 700 000 active
users
rumble who chris uh pavlovsky he was
with us what a couple weeks matter of
fact the day he announced the 100
million offer to
what he called rogan two days prior to
that we had the conversation about him
specifically doing something like that
and he went out there and did it ballsy
move good for him he obviously turned it
down but yeah everybody said hey this
guy's got that kind of money more power
to you right i think they said they have
what number did he say in the month of
january they had 39 million active users
but you got to realize they've been
around for nine years and it's not like
they're
just got started eight months ago and
they're going to 5 million right and he
is also trying to do what he's doing but
he's raising capital i was i want to go
back to the part about raising money
have you guys started raising money yes
i'm sorry fully funded yes so we are
funded by two international investment
firms one based in london one based in
the new york area uh so it's completely
privately funded right now uh we still
have what do i i think somewhere in the
neighborhood of like 10 20 million in
the bank but obviously we know that it's
a longer run to when we actually go and
start monetizing the platform obviously
the first aspects of revenue generation
won't come until april and then where it
really takes off is this summer um but
our backers know that there's a lot of
money quite frankly to be made in this
space but you have to spend a lot of
money together a lot of money a lot of
money and that's and here's the thing
too is we talk about kind of the pure
dollar challenges just being a
competitor platform the extra the way
that the bar is raised extra high just
on attracting engineers attracting
talent because everyone is so concerned
about getting blacklisted by google or
facebook you know uh what would happen
if big tech saw that i worked with a
challenger uh would this you know stop
me from getting jobs or going to the the
cool parties uh in
uh
nine months i'd get her what were you
doing i get her two and a half years at
getter two and a half years at rumble i
can see that blacklisted permanently to
work is that a challenge for the
engineers that you're hiring or is that
it so you know i'll tell you on this it
was at the beginning it's less so now in
fact a couple of weeks ago we hired
someone who had competing offers from
google and from us and they turned down
google they came with us and i was like
you know holy you know what i'm like
really like you're turned down google to
come with us and the person said look
i've been impressed i was a little
skeptical when you guys launched i
thought it might be like the other
platforms immediately got kicked off or
got banned i've seen what you guys have
done and i'm just so sick of the
discrimination he goes i'm not even a
republican i'm an independent but the
fact that if you're like if independent
in california basically means that
you're republican but you're afraid to
have your registration be that which i
can't blame them and he goes just
everybody knows like oh you're one of
them and he goes i'm just so sick of
that that discrimination that behavior i
want to go a place where at least look
he's not gonna be some card care and
republican at least he feels free so so
for youtube's alternative is rumble
every time youtube screws up rumble does
well krista as well and they get users
so the twitter's alternative used to be
parlor right parlor was the alternative
to uh twitter is that is that what was
was parliament alternative to facebook i
think it was uh i think
obviously
let them describe themselves but
probably probably more of a competitor
to twitter
and i would say that where we started is
you just pull up on the screen our our
timeline our scroll
i would say initially most closely a
marketplace competitor to twitter very
clean by the way it's very clean our
engineers are good you know i i
when i first came on board i and i
obviously i launched it but the other
engineers were working on before i came
on board the guy who started this he's
now like in his the elite engineer
he's now in his mid 50s went to usc
undergrad usc grad school worked for all
the big companies like mcdonald douglas
and oracle and the brain on this guy is
so great our cto that we have in place
now the guy has five degrees from mit
and when he said that in the interview i
was like okay this guy's lying go run a
background check who has five degrees
from mit and he's like yeah i think like
school stuff is fun and i can do it in
the evenings and weekends like what's
wrong with it like this guy's brain is
so big our deputy cto went to xinhua
which is like the the harvard plus yale
plus stanford of china he's now here
living in the u.s and will be
permanently living here in the u.s the
brains on these guys are so big i mean
i'm just the pretty face uh but these
guys are that was that was a joke for
anyone who's not seen i like that i like
the way you do i'm definitely i'm
definitely not the pretty face i like
the way you did i have the voice for
radio if you've ever had it but it's a
clean look these guys are so smart
because again
the two things that i said right at the
beginning i want this to be a global
company that can scale it has to look as
good if not better than anything big
tech is putting out otherwise people are
going to walk up and say yeah you know
twitter might be a bunch of you know
whats but their functionality is better
did you address what uh uh uh what's his
name rogan said when he got on your
platform and he says all of a sudden i
had 9.2 million followers and i don't
have 9.2 million followers i think you
addressed that you said you
uh showed how many
you would have that have to still join
but how many are getter followers right
there's something that you guys yeah
they would like and so it's again this
is one where
self-inflicted air uh easily could have
been what happened is the front half of
our engineering got out of sorts with
our back end uh we just started rolling
it out for a number of users where when
you post on getter it cross post it
shows up on twitter which is great then
you don't have to go and bounce around
and because a lot of people have
audiences especially content creators or
people who are in kind of the messaging
space or commentators
what happened was we got out there and
showed here's what the the total reach
is and so i have the combined uh twitter
and getter followers that's now split up
so you say here's how many getters
specific and here's how many totals so
say if you were to post something on
getter and you have cross posting
enabled then you see how many what your
total reach is we should have had that
done early on it should have been the
same time as the back end because the
back end is just now catching up we've
addressed it spoke with rogan's producer
again it's it's
you know you're going to make mistakes
with the startup it should have been
more clearly spelled out but we fixed
that okay sounds good and uh in regards
to uh
uh active users right now what was your
active active users uh who
you know were on the website last month
what would be the active users yeah so
on the the daily active user is right
about
obviously it fluctuates um it's just
under 500 000. daily daily really oh
yeah no this is this is maybe 500 000
that's a solid number oh it's a real
solid number and the community is so
engaged no when i when i say that people
are like wait really
um oh no it's it is a it is a big number
and in fact we've had just uh answer the
question you didn't ask about following
say you know rogan and tucker these
people coming on in january we grew by
we've held the audience and we actually
last week had our two highest days ever
as far as posting as far as the number
of posts
yes as far as the activity so that
number has held and actually gone up so
we're holding and keeping mobilized
these new people who came out of january
so it hasn't been kind of the dip and
then the drop we've been able to hold
them i i l the fact that there's
alternatives that's good for everybody
you know coffee bean is good for users
you know because it makes starbucks
realize they have to constantly cheap
coffee at dunkin donuts is good for
customers because it makes you
think hey starbucks cannot take you to
10 bucks or whatever burger king is very
good for users who go to mcdonald's i
mean neither one of them is good for you
but it's good for users because there's
competition can you show me uh the
junior's last tweet
in regards to truth network coming out i
think he just posted this time for some
truth breaking uh this is this was
donald trump's first post on truth
social get ready your favorite president
will see you soon i mean he's always
humble it's it's such a unique quality
of his but get ready your favorite
president will see you soon
and that's out there with truth social
now truth social would be more of a
comparison competitor to you guys as
well as to twitter right would you say
true social so here is so
the way that i think you got to look at
it isn't so much of here's one pie that
the alternative platforms have and
they're challenging each other and then
here's the big tech and the reason why
is facebook actually lost followers this
last quarter first time ever that
they've had a drop or they've lost
people twitter is the washington post
said i think megan mcgardell had a great
op-ed said their business model is
misery people just the the experience on
twitter have just been so negative and
nasty functionality is great twitter's a
well-oiled machine functionality wise
but just it's so negative a lot of
people are turned off from that
one thing to keep in mind is when
president trump was de-platformed and i
know this from my own market research
about 20 to 25 of his followers his
voters domestically from 20 20 20. quit
social media
didn't necessarily delete their accounts
but they stopped using social media they
were frustrated they were turned off
they said
this is all rigged by 20
of his voters yes so he had you know
just under 75 million people about 20 to
25 percent somewhere right in between
there now it makes sense why he's never
on twitter
so no exactly here's so here's what
happens when president trump announced
in october of this last year that he was
going to launch true social
over the next 10 days we had a 135
increase in signups versus the previous
10 days because here's what's happening
people are coming off the sidelines and
they're saying what's available what's
here we're here right now tour social is
not when president trump gets back in i
think it's going to get a lot more
people saying you know what maybe now's
the time this is the genesis this is the
spark point to go look at other
platforms that are not called big tech
so this isn't just a matter of us
fighting over some small pie twitter and
facebook are going to lose a lot of
people to both true social and to us
maybe even some other platforms one
trump gets in and starts getting people
jazzed up and here's everything to keep
in mind facebook and twitter it's not
like they're taking their foot off the
pedal the facebook in particular
launched their quote-unquote global
misinformation and global
anti-misinformation effort which means
that anyone have an election in 2022
philippines colombia brazil france
they're going around and essentially
picking winners and losers doing their
warning labels
doing the same nonsense that they did
with u.s elections so they're continuing
to drive people away on a daily basis
can you pull up the article from reuters
uh with trump about truth social sexual
terms opens on hundreds of testers out
of expected launch go go let me make it
a little bit bigger i want to read this
i haven't read this yet so reuters uh
details about foreign donald trump's new
social media app are trickling out as
about a 500
beta testers have begun using an early
version of truth social two sources told
reuters the testing of true social comes
a year after trump was banned from
facebook twitter and alphabet uh his new
media and technology venture trump
anderson has pledged to deliver an
engaging and censorship-free experience
on the app which uh chief executive
devin nunes has uh said will launch by
the end of march
uh truth remains shrouded in secrecy and
is regarded skepticism by some in tekken
media circles see the challenge with
this is the challenge with this is
he got a guy to go join him which is one
of the most powerful guys in tech
what is peter thiel doing resigning from
facebook board to go join him a
libertarian that wants to go join him he
must know something others don't a guy
like him is not going to go somewhere if
he doesn't think it's going to be a
winning formula and if he goes
he can probably make some phone calls to
recruit the best of the best engineers
because he's connected with everybody
and
they don't come as smart as that guy
does that guy's a very he doesn't want
attention he's low-key he doesn't want
to get out there and talk he just wants
to deliver and so that guy teaming up
with him and i know you're saying
this is going to help our platform but i
the only way i think it would
is if trump was actually active on
getter because
i if a user one of the most annoying
thing about a user is the following
here's what users are getting annoyed
with
a user wakes up and is like look i used
to just have to check facebook now i
gotta check facebook then i gotta check
twitter then i gotta check youtube then
i gotta check instagram then i gotta
check linkedin then i gotta check tick
tock then i gotta
now i gotta check it out now i gotta do
now i gotta it's so many things for me
to check off right so don't you think
this guy going out there and doing what
he does
it could possibly
uh because this is what a lot of people
are saying it could possibly
uh hurt some of the other startup
platforms out there like yours or maybe
even a rumble
so well that's the thing teal is a big
backer of rumble and so nobody is fake
and so right and so one of the things
also you got to keep in mind
teal leaving
um
facebook or meadow whatever they're
calling themselves now it's not as
though he's leaving meta to go do
something trump it's he's leaving i
think you have to go and bifurcate the
two here's the reason why facebook's a
dying company uh i mean even zuckerberg
said that they're gonna lose 45 percent
of their audience 18 and under over the
next two years it just i mean kids don't
have facebook they have snapchat and
tick tock that's where they're going to
well instagram too and they're on
instagram and it's well and they said so
this is kind of where i'm getting to the
functionality instagram reels this is
zuckerberg is the most recent uh
quarterly investor report
instagram reels the short video format
drives about 60
of their engagement that's anyone coming
to any of the broader instagram facebook
properties is for instagram reels that's
what the whole so that's what we
launched because they're hyping those up
and they're basically that's working
because that's kind of like tick tock
reels go viral reels can take off so so
and we actually just launched yesterday
again the beta testing as we we start to
scale up vision which is our short video
format so that's why i said initially
we're competitors with twitter and
facebook now we're launching a product
that ultimately will go head to head
with tick tock instagram reels this is
even before we get to say the get or pay
as we go into the the crypto
payment platform we have the other thing
we have that's really popular right now
is live streaming um and just to give
you a sense of the scope when president
trump had his rally in arizona last
month a million people
technically 996 000 that's i'll round up
to a million a million people watch
president trump's rally on getter over
three different channels you had right
side uh you had newsmax and you had a
real america's voice those combined so a
million out of our four and a half
million we're watching trump's rally
when he had his rally then in conroe
texas two weeks later yeah over 700 000
the live streaming dynamic that we've
added in
has been gangbusters not just here but
globally as well yeah that's one and
that's my concern because that's all
going to be on truth if he does that i
think it's a long play because even
truth
it's not it's not an easy thing to just
build something i would i would be
surprised i would be surprised i have
not seen from any of the beta testers
that they have live streaming in the in
the near future eventually
they'll sit there but also you got to
keep in mind at least i'm kind of too
young horn here we have the short vision
uh or the vision the short video clip
format which is again that's where
people are doing the fun dances and all
this stuff um that's that's what all the
younger folks are two that's now i
haven't seen that within the beta
testing for truth but then where we're
going ultimately keep in mind
where truth wants to go and this is from
their their public deck they want to be
an entertainment and media creation
company they want to create content
that's if you take a look at the deck
that's where they want to go we're going
as more into the the financial services
and payment platform in crypto uh aspect
and so they're going to be areas of
commonality but here's everything too
when you talk about people opening up
the multiple apps multiple social media
platforms right now people are looking
and saying yes you have your twitter
your facebook your others
i'm not so sure that as these new
platforms ours true social and others
start to pop up the people and say you
know what i have these
platforms i like i don't need to go to
twitter anymore i don't need to go to
facebook anymore i'll open up maybe
truth maybe we'll open up getter
maybe someone will open up parlor rumble
whatever the case those are the ones i'm
doing i don't need to worry about the
old big tech platforms who are censoring
me politically yeah you know i told us
to chris if you remember when we were
talking i said i said the the the what's
going to help today is you got to get
something on your show
on your platform that i can only get on
your platform right like what you were
talking about with earlier conversation
we're having with you being a pundit at
a couple different places and one of the
places you you were expressing what the
what the
terms and conditions was is
for example
why why did i go to spotify i've never
downloaded spotify until rogan went on
spotify i've never downloaded spotify
ever in my life until rogan went there
then i said i'm gonna go to spotify
right
you know bill maher to me right now is
one of the most valuable voices out
there because believe it or not i think
he is a voice of reason right you got
the right it's also a reflection of how
off track uh the american totally i love
what he said you know you always say he
says i i didn't change you changed i've
been the same for the last 30 years
still the same
so so i think he's very necessary i
think
uh our russell brand is very necessary i
think jon stewart jon stewart oh my gosh
if he came out of retirement whoever was
able to pick him up that guy's your good
friend hassan minaj
hassan minaj is
one of the highly requested guys to be
on the podcast guys want to have a
seminar funny guy yeah so
these guys are necessary i think like
you know you know it's just i think the
battle is very similar to hulu netflix
hbo show time like
when sasha baron cohen had his show on
showtime i'm like give me a damn break i
got to go order yeah you got a showtime
app right when you know
what's his name uh shia labeouf one of
my favorite actors his story that he
made that movie about the story of his
father honey boy something like that it
was only on amazon i had to go get
amazon's app on my
tv to see it right but house of cards is
why i joined netflix first if there
wasn't a house of cards i would have
never downloaded netflix right so it got
me in through house of cards so all i'm
saying is you i think this guy's not a
guy that's going to be a lightweight to
go out there and do what he's doing
trump because he's preparing his
campaign for 2024 and you know more than
i know he's running it's not like he
ain't gonna run no i spent three hours
with him yesterday afternoon yeah so i
wouldn't visit him at mar-a-lago oh i'm
gonna go see him this afternoon so
that's great i'll text you yeah
yeah so so he's kidding by the way he's
not he's not a guy that's a very but
although he had his best podcast a
couple days ago but he said people were
blown away by but but but the reason why
i say this reasonable people out there i
think i think you need someone to be a
face
that i can only get on
getter and you got to spend some money
to get somebody like that so i think so
to that point i think they're they're
yes you're exactly right i may be wrong
i'm just speculating no you're you're
right on a big party that's pat pitching
you to haste uh give us some money we'll
head out no no no no not at all i'm not
asking about us i'm not at all
here's the thing when we bring on the
content creators and we're able to and
again we'll undercut the competition and
come in they're allowing to keep that
much that much more money uh literally
been you know 50 to 100 percent less
than what anyone else has charged them
to take take the rip
off of it that's going to be a driver
for a lot of content creators we are
pursuing some additional partnership
deals to have some of that that creative
but also two
to your point just about people having
to bounce around to different platforms
with ours if you have the micro blogging
if you have the short video essentially
the tick tock the instagram reels type
you have the live streaming then you
also have this crypto and the payment
platform aspect that then makes it the
all-in-one free speech platform so
that's part of what we're doing is make
it so once you're there you're getting
everything you possibly want but there
there will be we're talking to some
folks we'll have some
crazy crazy question for you crazy when
you spent time with trump yesterday the
the three hours at mar-a-lago was there
ever a conversation of you know uh
bringing getter and truth together where
they use the pla any conversation like
that or not at all no comment
okay then that's the right strategy
here's the thing um
i think that there are there are areas
of of teaming up i think there are areas
where uh you know more than one platform
can exist in this space
certain things i just won't comment or
talk about but let's just say that uh
i'm still politically speaking i'm still
a big ally the president and very
friendly with them i think there's a way
for both platforms and the american
people to ultimately succeed in having
additional freedom in their voice that's
probably as far as i want to go okay got
it yeah
again
if a strategy like that were to take
place
it's
a
team up together to go up against an
enemy rather than you competing against
each other because if if their platform
is a different angle then getter is a
different angle uh it's like bringing
instagram and facebook together that was
a domination when that took place it's
like bringing
you know youtube and google together
holy so they went from being
competitors to together
top website i know in america right now
is tick tock they just blew past
everybody because of what they're doing
with their videos going viral but you
got google youtube facebook those three
guys competing for the top four so i
think that would be more of a unified
way to go to war
uh for the next two three years because
i think the alternate i think it's gonna
work i think someone's gonna pull this
off and do it the right way by the way
when you were with him how is his energy
how's he feeling is he uh uh planning on
uh uh every time when i see him speak
and in different events at mar-a-lago or
other places he sounds like he is
ready he's warming up for 20. you know
we spend
i think this probably might surprise
people we spent a good chunk going
through a lot of policy type things and
he has a c cpac speech that's coming up
not this weekend but next weekend so we
talk through some of the themes
different things he's going to hit on we
talk through endorsements some people
he's endorsing not going to endorse he
started rolling a bunch of those out
last night earlier uh this morning but i
think
the the seriousness and the focus that
he has right now what's going on with
russia in ukraine
but then also the even bigger
existential threat which is china uh
russia and ukraine i don't want to
trivialize it and say that it's just
noise but compared to china and taiwan
it is noise that's the real threat
because china is going to take taiwan
and they'll do in about 10 minutes and
then everyone else in the south china
sea or anywhere else in the indo-pacific
needs to be on high alert i think
ultimately might be proven wrong as i
saw there's some mortar shells fired
this morning
just in ukraine i think putin probably
wants to make sure there's no nato or eu
expansion um he shores up his domestic
political base by kind of rattling the
saber um he
does something where it makes it look
like biden is weak and he's strong and
then he kind of just rides off in the
sunset and he rattles his saber
somewhere else i think that's probably
what happens with ukraine and russia
but china's a whole different can of
worms if if you're a betting man and you
go to las vegas
and you have the odds to bet on him
running versus not running you're
betting on what oh he's he'll run he'll
run he'll ride
he did not use those exact words
um but i mean he talked in pretty uh
speci as far as the desire the
motivation and part of the thing is like
look he's like if you have someone who's
weak in the white house you're going to
get tested by these foreign leaders
they're just going to steamroll you and
it's a i think a lot of times people see
kind of the you know kind of the affable
and some of the you know sometimes
hyperbolic aspect of the president and
they don't necessarily see sometimes the
the concern level he's really concerned
about the direction of the country with
everything happened with immigration and
inflation and all these different issues
going on he's concerned that if someone
like him doesn't get back in there what
the country is going to look like after
not just the next three years but four
years after that so so then the the
question then for you becomes
uh this is a question i've i've been you
know been trying to get an answer from
somebody we had the press secretary of
uh desantis here christina push-ups
right uh and
she was a great uh she was great at
playing dodgeball i mean like she was
she wasn't a great dodgeball player
she was dodging everything but every
time i was asking like this it was very
impressive but uh this is this is a a
state where they love their governor
and in some communities they love their
former president in this state right so
they're conflicted in the state of
florida
a lot of people on the center
and on the right would like to see the
santis get in the ring and compete for
the number one spot which is to be the
president
there's even some people on the left
that would be more happier with a
desantis than they would be with a
trump as a president right
uh but right now if you go out there and
you look at who's going to be the
you know candidate for the right knowing
the percentage-wise trump's at the top
he's got a good lead on the sentence
right
and if this in the then the question
becomes well if desantis doesn't run
right now
you know politics people got a short
memory you know because newsome maybe
they're canada in 2023 2024 and people
forget about what happened in california
so that's my pre i think it's trump
versus newsham in 2024 by the way okay
got it so so so so you don't think the
santa's gonna run this year in 2023 2024
i think that i think uh governor
desantis wants to run uh i think that
desantis is a powerhouse i think that he
would uh if the election were tomorrow
and trump was not in the race desantis
would he'd be the next president of
course if he's not right the one thing
that i would say i i don't i i don't
know about president i think he would
have a very high chance of being a
president but i think he would take the
republican side the nominee
i've seen i've seen polling that says
that again if president trump did not
run and the election were tomorrow so
it's not based on going through the
campaign trail and the gauntlet and and
by the way it's a long road to the
coordination so a lot of you know a lot
of the roadside's littered with
candidates who are the front-runner and
then they get that wrong or that one
weird question or they get tripped up or
people see some weird awkwardness about
them or something like that and they
they stumble
ron would win the gop primary and then
he would be whoever the democrat nominee
is it's just that
biden's really screwed things up for the
political left right now
i do think that president trump runs i
think maybe to your point again this is
not something i'm not saying this from
anything he told me yesterday because we
didn't go into
anything specific but
look you take a trump desantis ticket
something like that would be pretty damn
powerful in my opinion um and maybe a
team up there might be a smart thing
that uh that helps the gop take it
overall i don't i don't know if that
happens
i don't know if that happens these are
two alphas i i just i have a hard time
seeing desantis doing that uh but but at
the same time if they go at each other
what does it look like if they both run
i've seen all the quotes all the things
trump has said i would beat him too you
know with you know the booster shot hey
people ask me if i took the booster i
did some people are afraid to see i've
followed all the stories everything
that's been happening but uh what
happens if both of them run
is that a good thing or
it's
i'd prefer to avoid it uh i still think
trump wins uh i don't even think that
it's it's ultimately close
uh but it would uh i think that again
ron's a powerhouse trump's a bigger
powerhouse what about his relationship
with pence these days pence may be
considering running as well they haven't
exactly uh
mince words as of late i don't know
where where's things stand with pence
yeah i don't think they're hanging out
on the weekends anymore so i think that
that ship has probably sailed so
any chance that if trump uh runs again
that the uh pence would be his vp
nomination at all
i can't see it it's zero i think it's
zero i don't think it's possible
i don't think it's possible for that to
happen but indeed would run though no
don't you think
like looking on stage you see a trump
you see a pence you see a nikki haley
you see a desantis
what does that look like there and
there's here's the reality if you look
at the polling
um
desantis has already clearly passed pets
even if even if president trump did not
run for some reason uh if president
trump did not run i do think pence
definitely then runs uh and uh if i were
advising him i'd say not to because i
think desantis would uh would clean his
clock
the santas will clean this clock pence's
yes yeah i don't disagree you see trump
and pence
debating on stage
i mean certainly if uh
i mean if there was a primary field that
had primary debates i think actually i
think trump would probably love that
it would be it'd be you know it'd be
made for uh tv excitement i don't think
pence would do it i don't think pence is
going to run
because the this okay so what's pence's
uh message going to be let's actually go
there first debate they're on stage i
was with trump 99.9 of the time until
january 6th insurrection so okay so who
does he get he gets the lincoln project
folks yep he gets the bush camp he gets
mcconnell who does he get karl rove he
gets karl rove he gets those guys that's
who he's gonna get okay what happened to
moment biden one what did they do to
lincoln project
nothing they realized you're left out
there too so lincoln project is also
sitting there
they're probably behind closed doors
hoping for a desantis hoping for
somebody else because those guys are not
going to support trump but pensa's
argument is going to be it's
only going to last for a week or two
before he's done i don't think that's
going to last um but don't forget that
pence was a nobody before trump made him
well i will tell you this
i get what you're saying i get what no
he has a point to say when to me how i
interpret that is
he wasn't mainstream that's a better way
of saying it not that he was a nobody i
will tell you a lot of people voted for
trump because they were glad pence was
the vp so you can't say he was a nobody
especially
so if you think about if you think about
percentage-wise out of all the votes he
got when he beat hillary okay what
percentage you think was uh was pence so
i can tell you just put a little numbers
to that
in the final debate that president trump
had in toward the end of it when he
answered the question about supreme
court picks is it in 16 uh yes and 16
sorry
in 2016.
we our numbers went from mid high 80s
with republicans to
low mid 90s with republicans after that
answer because people heard the okay
these pro-life they once conservative
supreme court judges support the second
amendment
but it's it's that was much more of the
pence voter they kind of took it from
the the mid high 80s to the low mid 90s
so you're exactly right there there was
a definitely community of folks that
pushed them over and 77 000 votes
over six states yeah you could say pence
was a huge part of trump i want to read
the story political insider story
mcconnell bush gop establishment working
to fall trump endorsed candidates senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell's
working behind the scenes to protect and
strengthen gop establishment figures
sometimes in direct opposition to former
president trump and mcconnell isn't
alone either at his side at least one
instance is former president george w
bush one such case in arizona senate
race trump has been highly critical of
governor doug ducey over the state's
performance in 2020 election while ducey
has demurred on running for senate in
2022 he's gotten encouragement from the
likes of mcconnell and george bush
mcconnell has stated that he believes
that trump has uh done damage to the gop
and told allies told allies that he will
not be back unelectable goofballs in the
primaries
what do you have to say about that
are you surprised no not surprised at
all i mean that's the the swamp hates
president trump and they hate anyone
who's not going to conform he's not
going to go and fall in line
i do think that uh we need to make sure
that we're uh vetting candidates and
make sure that we have solid ones that
are gonna be there and i think the
president has i think president trump
has a smarter more robust effort
built around him for this time for what
candidates he's backing as and look
there'll be some places where you see
uh you know the the swamp type folks
plus trump being on the same page on
some of these endorsements there'll be
places where they're undifferent so so
say trump runs 2023 okay
and by the way right now if you bet a
hundred dollars in vegas uh on the bet
of trump running the return is only a
dollar yeah i was gonna say that because
everybody
yeah
but but say he runs who do you see
because what i'm what i'm interested in
is give me a list of people that are his
enemies
that we know of and then give the
potential unexpected enemies that will
fight against them not being president
so let's talk about the people that we
know are enemies is mainstream uh going
to support him
well and mainstream as maybe a wrong
word that i used i'd say the the
washington uh the swamp creatures
they're not going to support them
they're not going to support it okay um
i do think that the the overall
republican base is pretty solidly with
trump so so go to the swamp give me
names on the right that you would
consider swamp mcconnell's one yeah what
else would you put swamp uh i mean you
go into i mean you listened number
earlier whether big mcconnell whether it
be rove i know where it might
technically live in in texas but he's
viewed as being kind of the
establishment that
george w bush types uh that are there um
i would say
anyone who voted in the liz cheney types
even though she's going to be out of
office here there's zero chance that she
wins her her race in wyoming uh but
those are the types got it so so number
one number of commerce the the the
chamber of commerce the swamp
is not going to support him on the right
who else will be those that wouldn't
support him that would fight him tooth
and nails to make sure he doesn't get
elected well and so this word starts to
get a little bit more stilted i think
it's tough to say that there's
the law enforcement and the legal system
has not become politicized against
president trump when you look at say the
state of new york you look at tish james
you look at some of these activists
attorneys general
i think it's become very politicized i
think the fact that tisch james ran in
saying that she was going to lock up
president trump this is the attorney
general of the state of new york
campaigning saying i'm going to win and
then we're going to lock up donald trump
what kind of impartial law enforcement
activist
is this i mean this thing is is so
politicized that i i think it's really
just a
egregious abuse of our uh our judicial
system so you can say but then i'd also
say um and this kind of goes to i know
another thing we're going to talk about
you look what they did with trump with
all the the spying and the data
collection and things like that from
2016 and even beyond i don't put it
above even biden's white house or
biden's doj
to go and pull some of the same
shenanigans again okay so so far we got
the swamp a part of the mainstream media
you got uh some of the uh government the
uh
uh the police or the lincoln project
crew steve schmidt all those guys then
the last one you just talked about here
with what's gonna happen potentially joe
biden similar thing to what happened
with the durham investigation hillary
pulled off obama gate to maybe biden
doing that uh who else you think will be
you think do you think the facebooks of
the world you think those guys are going
to be overly
playing the control game to make sure
not necessarily trump they've already
done that but other people that are
coming up hey candace owens that all of
a sudden does alive and gets 22 million
views well let's silence her you think
there's going to be a lot more stories
like that happen the next couple years
absolutely here's one of the kind of the
the buried leads or untold stories the
progressive left really took it out on
jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg after
trump won in 2016. and they said it's
because of you you guys came up with
those platforms you allowed trump to
evade the media go directly to people
it's on you i think that's a big part of
the reason we saw zuckerberg then go and
fund some of the election efforts uh
with the dropboxes and the things of
that nature kind of the good is he would
probably probably describe a good
government and pro-voting but he
basically was funding he knew what he
was funding um but the uh
that's why you saw so much of the
backlash they changed the rules of the
game in 2020 they said okay trump you're
not gonna have the unfettered access
we're gonna suspend you where necessary
we'll put up the warning labels and now
post election they ultimately banned
them from their accounts so i think that
will ratchet up even higher and that's
part of the thing you look at again not
where the ball is right now but where
it's going is we go into these elections
not just the 2022 midterms or even 2024.
facebook and twitter have already made
that business decision that they want
some people as customers and others they
don't want as customers not just in the
us but around the world
they're both of those platforms are
going to lose tremendous amounts of
people as they come in and exercise
additional acts of political
discrimination well we saw that when
they lost 240 billion in a day facebook
that's a lot of money to lose in a day
240 in a single day so who
who will be the supporters go on the
flip side now who will be the supporters
and who will be the surprising
supporters so one and again there's
you probably already aware of this one i
think uh latinos and hispanic americans
will be big drivers for trump and part
of the reason is this
democrats made a just a fundamental
miscalculation when they backed the blm
movement the way they did in 2020 that
just with the the lawlessness and the
the acts of looting and everything that
that we saw come out of those those
rights and protests
i think that you have a lot of white
democrats in washington who don't
understand the hispanic and latino
american communities at all i think it's
purely just about economics you travel
to central and south america and people
have eight nine-foot walls around their
house or eight nine foot gates and in
walls and fences things of that nature
it's because it's not safe i mean go to
columbia and even good neighborhoods you
have the the uniformed officers with
with machine guns uh it's because of the
challenges they've had it's not just
about economics it's also about security
people want to live in a place where
their kids can walk to school without
being potentially abducted or killed or
shot or something of that nature and by
democrats embracing the blm movement
they i think they did a generation worth
of damage to their relationship with the
latino and hispanic american communities
and you saw that not just
in the rio grande i think latino
americans would be the surprising driver
for trump i also think too
look trump got a lot of people forget
this trump did record setting well for
with latino americans black americans
asian americans best ever for a
republican since 1972 and i think that
movement by african-americans away from
the democratic party that whether they
be going to independents or going to
republican i think that's continuing
because quite frankly i don't think
democrats would make good on their
promises to black americans at all
jason you have trump's ear do you not i
mean you met with him yesterday right
how open is he to your feedback
good question um sometimes he likes it
he has no problem telling me if he
thinks it sucks
which is always fun he's like hey i like
that idea or actually that's a terrible
idea let me tell you why but when you
when you work with president trump your
job isn't to
your job is not going to try to tell him
what to say or necessarily
you might have ideas different things
but your job is to figure out how to
amplify what he's thinking what
direction he's going uh yeah there'll be
things for example when we talked about
uh his speech coming up at cpac got a
couple specific ideas on themes i think
he ought to go and hit on uh but he is
uh probably more than anyone i've ever
worked with i mean he's his own guy he's
gonna uh
it's fun you know so it's great when he
listens to him and sometimes he has i'll
give you one just quick example
2016 he's going to roll out his economic
plan and i wouldn't present it to him i
was like sir you know just kind of make
fun of myself here i'm like sir here's
this detailed plan that you know the
entire team got together and worked on
this rollout plan for us and he just
kind of looks at me and he goes jace how
long did you spend working on that and i
was like uh-oh
i'm like oh sir just you know the team
whipped together you know a couple hours
he's like no you spent did you guys
spend days working on this he shakes his
head and he goes let me tell you this
i'm sure this stuff is all fine this is
so washington here's how we're going to
do it i'm going to call it matt lauer on
the today show he's going to take me
live i'm going to deliver it to four or
five million people live
it's going to get everyone talking the
entire day ted cruz won't even um or
hillary clinton won't even be out of bed
yet by the time i roll out my economic
policy we're getting all this buzz going
we can go do some other stuff but um you
know come and talk to me on this kind of
thing so he's always thinking through
kind of the marketing and the
presentation and i kind of looked i was
like he's kind of right um you know and
the piece of paper i had wasn't even
worth it so it's uh he'll tell you if if
he doesn't agree with you
and if you had a magic wand and you can
reverse history and
change one thing that you think he did
wrong is there anything that comes to
mind
yeah i think in 2020 and i'll take some
of the blame on this we should have our
own social media platform ready to go
and i will be the first person to tell
you that i did not take as serious
the
the censorship and the political
discrimination that we saw going and i
should have realized that from early
2020 wasn't purely about electoral
politics remember people were being
sentenced to digital jail because they
said the virus came from a lab and wuhan
well you know spoiler alert it did come
from a lab and wuhan we don't know if it
was man-made or if it was traipsed out
by a sloppy worker but it came from a
lab in wuhan and people are being
sentenced to digital jail if you
criticize fauci in the wrong way you're
getting sentenced to digital jail even
before we got to the hunter biden laptop
and trump's ultimate de-platforming
we should have realized that we needed
to have additional platform or platforms
out there that would have obviously
needed to start in 2018 2019 you go and
build that up i look back and that's the
one thing that i say that we all drop
the ball on we should have that up and
going what are your thoughts on the
sixth what are your thoughts on the sick
like how
the mcconnell and the left sells it and
then how many on
the mega camp and trump's camps sell
january 6th yeah i mean look i'll tell
you what i think of it just you know
unvarnished i think it was a terrible
day for american history and i think the
the images that we saw in that day are
terrible and we can never have that
happen again uh i do not hold president
trump responsible for anything that
happened on that day
anyone who's a trump supporter after we
had spent how many different speeches
and ads and everything saying we support
law enforcement we support law and order
how how anyone could go and do that
that's why i've always had questions
about just how much how really some of
these people were actually trump
supporters where they were rabble
rousers or if they're you know some
people who just had a screw loose uh i
do think that it's unfortunate what the
unfortunate too light of a term i think
it's it's pretty disgusting what the doj
has done on people who say for example
didn't enter the capital i think if
you're again you can be outside the
capitol there's no law against that if
you want to go out there and say
go and send these back to the states to
have further debate on that's fine no
one should be having any either civil
liberties infringed upon or have their
life ruined simply because they're
outside the capitol if you were if you
assaulted any police officers if you
destroyed any property
then i think you need to be fully held
accountable for everything that you did
if you're outside peacefully protesting
so what people protest outside the
capitol all the time and
uh but again it's the images of that day
are things that for a lot of people it's
going to define an entire generation
politically so on on j on
i don't know what day would this was the
one year anniversary this year when ted
cruz said the following of all the
things that january 6 was it was
definitely not a violent terrorist
terrorist attack he said that the next
day but you know later on that day but
earlier that day he said it was a
it was a insurrection it was a terrorist
attack and tucker carlson came out i'm
sure he saw that and he
hold his held his foot to the fire and
said hey what is this and he said no no
that's not what i meant he says look
you're a man of words you know words
you're a guy that knows words you said
it did you mean it how could you say
something like that you realize the
repercussions of this and it was a very
uncomfortable day for ted cruz do you
think do you think that was by the way
your mic is on do you think that was a
situation where ted
was maybe that morning he's like this is
an opportunity where i can go and i have
to have a different position than trump
if i'm gonna run myself you know do you
think that was one of those moments or
do you think he just had a bad day and
he said the wrong thing so
i worked for ted in the primary in 2016
before i went to before i went to trump
and
uh
just doing the quick rewind if trump had
run in 2012 i was gonna be his campaign
manager and i just assumed he was never
going to run i thought he got his
apprentice deal renegotiated he was
gonna stick that so signed up and
partnered up with ted
ted
doesn't make mistakes speaking
i can't speak to what his thought
process was
i i've i've never seen him actually
misspeak i mean he's so i don't know
what all he was thinking or went into it
i am glad that that he went and cleaned
it up uh i still think ted's a pretty
important voice but i would disagree as
far as the you know the the insurrection
talk or saying that this is some kind of
terrorist thing i would i would disagree
with that yeah i'd be curious because i
think trump's got a memory and he will
remember comments like that being made
you think i know i i think that's either
going to work in his favor or it's not
going to work in his favor you know it's
meaning ted i'm not talking about trump
because
you know
you think romney's going to play any
kind of a role in the next two three
years or he's done he does that he is so
dumb i mean he's i i don't even know how
he'd get re-elected he's young compared
to biden and trump
uh he is i thought romney was how old is
romney he's he's in his 70s
right i don't think it's that big of a
difference i think that i think it's i
thought he was late 60s is what i was
he's also saying mate 74. got it well he
looks good
i'm not going to that's right that's
what some of that that sweet bang cash
will do
what do you think happens with the gop
establishment the romney's of the world
the cheney's the the mcconnells
and the
you know
mega crowd like what's that relationship
look like moving forward yeah there's
always going to be an inherent conflict
and i don't even think it's necessarily
unique just to republicans i think it
might take a different form but you see
even with
the democrats and the progressives and
the people who want to change washington
from the right or the left uh and then
people who say actually we're washington
we're the ones you know this is the
hunger games this is capital city we're
the ones who make the decision the rest
you guys just just go and live with it
there's always going to be inherently
something and look it is i will tell you
this whole changing washington thing is
really damn tough uh it's like going to
the casino and saying i'm going to beat
the house it's like these people who say
i'm going to beat the
i'm going to beat the doj in some kind
of legal thing they have unlimited money
uh unlimited resources and they're just
going to keep pounding away
there's always gonna be some of that
conflict but as far as the the
republican base overall nationally it's
solidly with trump i mean you look at
the way that he single-handedly changed
the trade debate you look at the way
that he's single-handedly uh changed so
many of these uh the international
relations the america first dynamic i
mean you know it was only a decade ago
that you know someone coughs somewhere
and we're sending us troops five minutes
later now we're taking much more of a
wait a minute do we need to go and stick
our nose into in all these efforts
that's all because of trump and just the
fact that biden has left so many of
trump's china policies in place i think
it just tells you how much trump has
moved not just even the republican base
but the country as a whole into
realizing the the existential threat to
china for the long term that's that's uh
that's that in itself you know if you
were to biden camp how would you sell
that you're you're a campaign manager
for biden how would you sell the fact
that you've kept many of trump's china
policies well he went on this you just
claim him as your own
well
yeah i don't know about that i think
you're you're right i mean that's that's
what uh
that's what a amateur campaign manager
is going to say right that's what an
amateur campaign manager is going to say
but this is an opportunity to come out
and you know win the opposite side and
the guys in the middle to say listen at
least this guy's being given some kind
of credit on what happened there but you
have to stand to your point you know and
say well this is our ideas well we have
to we got rid of every single idea that
he had the only thing he the only thing
biden can do is say actually trump
wasn't tough enough we went even further
the country is so moved uh in the other
direction with regard to china i think
we are moving towards uh a true deca
it's never going to be a complete
decoupling uh but you see the way that
it's it's going i mean these these uh
the decoupling of these economies is
happening
so
let's let's talk about the durham
investigation that just came out the
durham report okay if you want to this
is a daily mail article the timeline of
durham's
investigation leading up to the
bombshell hillary clinton if you can
pull up that article so folks can see it
as i'm going through it
may 17th 2017 then deputy attorney
general rod ron
rason
rosenstein
appoints robert mueller as special
counsel this is may 17 2017.
among other things mueller is directed
to investigate any links and or
coordination between the russian
government and individuals associated
with trump presidential campaign okay
then we go to january 15 bill barr first
alluded to what would become the durham
investigation in a senate confirmation
hearing he promised then judiciary
chairman lindsey graham he would examine
the fbi's counterintelligence
investigation against trump
march 22nd 2019 mueller closes special
investigation to russian meddling in
2016 election
and submitted his final report to barr
march 25th three days later 2019. barr
met with then connecticut attorney
general john durham justice department
records show the two had 18 more
meetings and three calls that year
december 2019 durham was revealed to be
examining the role of obama-era cia
director john brennan
in how the intelligence community assess
russia's 2016 election interference
september 17 20 21st this is five months
ago cyber security
2021 cyber security lawyer michael
sussman pleaded not guilty in federal
court he was indicted for lying to the
fbi in a 2016 meeting where he shared
information related to ties between the
trump organization and russia afla bank
he said he wasn't working for a client
but was hired by hillary clinton's 2016
presidential campaign two months later
november 2021 durham charged russia born
and analyst igor danchenko would line to
the fbi in fabricating sources for the
steele dossier he pleaded not guilty to
five counts of making false statements
to a federal agent
last week february 11 2022 durham
filings revealed
clinton paid
to have trump tower and white house
servers heckled to fabricate ties
between trump and russia
and then trump era director national
intelligence john radcliffe reveals
durham thinks there is enough evidence
to indict several more people he also
said obama and biden were briefed on the
clinton revelations in 2016. okay
what what are your thoughts about what's
been happening with this year with the
durham report
i wish it happened a year ago or two
years ago or several years ago why
didn't it though
i think
yeah this is just my
my speculation on this
i think that
barr
knew that there were egregious abuses
but he didn't want to do anything that
would become a 2020 campaign issue and
so he wanted to get to the bottom of
this but he was so concerned about him
him he himself looking politicized that
he didn't want to do it here's the
problem you literally wasted i should
say wasted because he got some great
things done
but that first two years of the the
trump administration how many tens of
millions of dollars how many cnn
interviews how many msnbc broadcasts and
shows
devoted purely to all the mola molar in
in russia russia russia nonsense
how much money and time and effort was
wasted into all of this
i mean even this moeller report in what
we know what started it
ultimately you have this steele dossier
which helped to swirl up suspicion but
disproven you have all these alpha bank
allegations that were used to swirl up
suspicion now it's coming back sussman
is going to be um
have a nice custom fitted orange suit at
a certain point here and that's good
he's you know probably not going to like
his time in a cell
but here's the thing i think everybody
is missing from this who gave these guys
their orders now we saw in the closing
days of 2016 we saw jake sullivan by the
way the current national security
advisor for biden in the white house
wrote a memo about these alleged trump
ties that hillary then tweeted out and
was talking about
we saw hillary bring it up just uh just
before halloween in uh in 2016 uh with
the whole trump russia uh connections or
the alleged connections
so clearly there's communication in the
clinton camp sussman was billing the
clinton campaign for his work why is
nobody saying who gave him his orders
who signed off on the approvals what was
the the chain of custody and chain of
command for reporting that information
back up
i i think the uh the rotting fish here
uh goes up i don't know if it's to the
actual head but i think it goes higher
up there's there's no way this is all
just a are you obama is that kind of
where you're going are you going you're
going hillary you're going biting you're
going obama i i don't know but but i
know that this is not uh michael sussman
did not drive this entire thing by
himself yeah this is
jake sullivan
oh but that's uh but that's i mean this
jake sullivan just make you bigger is
the national
security advisor in biden's white house
today here's crooked on uh october 31st
on halloween 2016
going to this statement uh this memo
that jake sullivan put together
and talking about the i mean where did
this magically it's not like you just
let me read it because everybody's seen
this picture let's just read it make it
a little bit statement from jake solomon
on new report exposing trump's secret
line of communication to russia in
response to a new report from uh
state
showing that the trump organization has
a secret server registered to trump
tower that has been
covertly communicating with russia
hillary for uh american senior policy
adviser jake sullivan released the
following statement on monday this could
be the most direct link between donald
trump and moscow computer scientists
have apparently uncovered a covert uh
server link the trump organization to
russian-based bank
the secret hotline may be the key to
unlocking the mystery of trump's ties to
russia it
certainly seems the trump organization
felt it had something to hide given that
it apparently took steps to conceal the
link between it was discovered by
journalists this type of communication
may help explain trump's bizarre
adoration for vladimir putin endorsed of
so many pro-criminal positions
throughout his campaign it raises even
more troubling question in light of
russia's masterminding of heckling
hacking efforts that are clearly
intended to hurt hillary clinton's
campaign i can't read that part there
anyway so so
hitler
the next line says we can only assume
that federal authorities will now
explore this direct connection between
trump and russia again jake sullivan now
the national security adviser he was the
policy director for hillary's campaign
in 2016. national security adviser
what's going to happen to him
well that's what i'm saying that's why
jim jordan's been going after him saying
number one we got it in josh hawley has
also lit him up saying this guy we got
to make sure he doesn't have any
connection with any doj investigations
or anything that's going on because
concerned about that he might go and try
to scuttle things or try to cover it i
think i think
sullivan needs to be hauled up in front
of congress uh i think law enforcement
needs to talk to him
there's i want to know about every
communication that sussman and sullivan
have had and that's where i don't get
maybe this is what durham's referring to
and he's just being overly coy at this
point but they need to be asking so uh
sussman what exact communications was he
having with sullivan or anyone else on
the qriket's campaign so so to be fair
hillary responded yesterday when she was
walking out of a car somebody said so
what do you have any comments on durham
and she didn't say anything right but
this is what she tweeted i actually want
to read the
article from vanity fair so uh hillary
clinton yesterday uh
trump and fox are desperately spinning
up a fake scandal to distract from his
real ones so it's a day that ends in why
the more he misdeeds are the more his
misties are exposed the more they lie
for those interested in reality here's a
good debunking of the latest response
okay go up a little bit before you click
on that
go go up a little bit i won't see how
many likes it got okay
for a tweet like that okay how many
followers does hillary have go click on
her profile just to see him just click
yeah
31 million followers okay go go up a
little bit to show the tweet
go up a little bit to show that tweet
that she had up okay maybe then just
okay there you go
for somebody have 30 million followers
for only 30 000 people to like your post
the biggest name that really said
anything positive to defend her with
keith oberman which keith oberman hasn't
had credibility for a long time but
click on vanity fair click on vanity
fair let's read the article
uh let's read this our golden it's not a
long article by the way okay so let's
see who wrote it go find out who wrote
it who wrote it what's her name
best levin
do we know who best 11 is
no but i like that uh hillary had to
revert to vanity fair to uh well we know
we know we know where you know vanity
fair leans but let the article
let me read the article go a little
lower i mean the headline what was the
headline yeah unless breaking of the
headlines you'll never believe it but
hillary did not in fact spy on trump's
white house okay cool let's read it
uh go lower let's read it all right so
make it a little bit bigger so i can see
it from here
imagine if you will that a special
counsel appointed by the federal
government declared in a court filing
that he had evidence that a major
political figure
let's call her hillary clinton had paid
spies to infiltrate the white house and
run surveillance on donald trump in
order to frame
him as a foreign asset the whole thing
would be a big flipping deal one for
which there would be major major
consequences and far-reaching fallout
the country nay uh uh the world would be
griped uh gripped by the story and for
reason good reason a former candidate
for office spying on the president in
the white house and that would be crazy
and you're right it would be crazy if
something like that actually had
happened which it didn't
though unfortunately for some reason
logic and the concept of the true donald
trump fox and various other deranged
conservatives cannot be convinced of
that yes as you've probably heard on
saturday the former president released a
statement claiming that special donor he
meant to say gendron but was apparently
too angry to keep his johns and his
robert strait but has
uncovered indisputable evidence that my
campaign has presidency were spied on by
operatives paid a hillary clinton
campaign an effort to develop a
completely fabricated connection to
russia okay so far we don't have any
details just opinion a scanner for
greater in scope and magnitude than
watergate for which trump suggested
those involved should be executed but
would settle for criminal prosecution
the problem neither john not neither
robert durham
nor john durham nor anyone else for that
matter has actually provided evidence
for such crime let alone even suggested
it all right so let's see what this says
when john durham the trump air special
counsel investigating the inquiry into
russia 2016 election interference father
uh uh pre-trial motion on friday night
he slipped in a few extra sentences
that set off a fear among right-wing
outlets about perpetrated spying on okay
i don't know entire narrative appear
mostly wrong okay there's no explanation
here the latest example began with the
notion
that mr motion mr doramus falls and goes
against a michael a sussman cyber
security lawyer with links to democratic
party the prosecutor has accused mr
sussman of line during a september 26th
meeting with the fbi official about
donald trump's
possible links with russia the filings
was uh austin uh how do you pronounce
that word ostensibly ostensibly about
potential conflicts of interest but it
also recounted a meeting meeting at
which mr sussman had pre presented other
suspicions to the government in february
okay so go down is there any more
details than just to say it's not right
according to the filing suspense had
gotten information from technology
executive
rodney jaffe which whose company nustar
had performed server related work to the
white house and durham's estimation
jaffee and his colleagues had exploited
this arrangement by mining
for the purpose of gathering derogatory
information about donald trump fox news
took those lines from durham's filing
and ran with it claiming durham had said
that found the clinton campaign at pay
technology company infiltrate white
house server the lack of
similarly baseless claims
from the mainstream media let trump to
declare the press refuses to even
mention the major crime that took place
this is itself a scandal the fact that
the story is so big so powerful it's
okay all right got it so she's just
saying in other words
i don't think anything was there yeah i
don't see a
detailed breakdown
hillary didn't say anything hillary just
said that vanity fair went and disputed
it and this is another day ending and
why it's not a denial from hillary
clinton how do you read that well i
guess here's the question and to your
point
you said hey i wish this happened two
years ago
what i'm asking is if hillary was
running again in 2024 and i obviously
were speculating she could only whatever
it could be aliens i don't think she's
going anywhere right
but
then this would be a major story right
think of benghazi think of the email
think of the servers these are things
they could use against her
but if she's not running
and
you know we're talking about this robert
durham john durham report
is this a story that just kind of dies
on the vine where's it going because
there's no one derail again says hillary
hillary it's like dude we're in 2024
you're talking about 2016. where's the
relevancy here if she was still running
i could understand that why is that
important
because a lot of this uh spying happen
after the 2016 election when you talk
about trump's white house obviously that
only happens after january 20th 2017
when he's inaugurated and he takes in so
it goes even beyond the 2016 campaign
then into um
ostensibly the 2020 campaign and the
concern is with so much uh
so much going on as far as hacking or
government surveillance or monitoring i
want to know also how far did that go
did it just magically stop in say
january february of 2017 did it go
further we saw this computer firm also
worked for the uh the biden campaign i
we want to make sure this never happens
again from anybody that there's this uh
is now again the digital snooping and
spying i even have concerns even from
the government side well i guess my
question is this i i think it's a it's
it's a
it's a two-part question a is this
important to figure out yes
this is clearly important sixty-six
percent of democrats yeah i know yeah
yeah yeah
yes let's find out what happened here
sure yeah unbiased on control like let's
figure out
but b
what relevancy does it have for future
elections meaning is this help the trump
campaign get elected again in 2024 does
this hurt like that's that's what i'm
saying because because then then then
then the same question can be asked in a
following way uh a
do we have to know go back to 2016 when
everybody was saying russia russia
russia
you know
do we have to find out if trump was
linked to russia okay and then b but who
cares if it did you know what uh
are we gonna get out of it if we did
find out it's the same question but
everybody in the media wanted to know it
i mean there's there's clips if you want
to do greatest hits don lemon saying all
they talk about is a durham
investigation durham investigation
during my investigation it's out now you
know
rachel maddow's like everybody's relying
on the durham investigation there's
nothing it's just a conspiracy theory
okay you know
morning joe they keep talking about the
durham investigation but there's nothing
they're relying on they addressed this
specifically head-on on morning joe
today i don't know if you heard what
they said they had an expert come on and
really
sort of defuse the argument it's
something you should watch right look
what i'm saying is this diffuse the
argument meaning it's not a big deal
exactly that's this this and this was
not on the news two days ago when i kind
of was like hey what the hell is going
on here
it's just there's so much out there and
there's only so much bandwidth someone
can take i'm saying from the mind of an
individual voter
so how many people actually voted a
certain way because of benghazi as an
example maybe the emails especially when
comey came out and kind of said it was a
sloppy job so i tell you there are a
couple things here because it's it's not
even just about say the pure partisan
aspect the the democrats it's also about
the media so why is morning joe out
there doing it well number one they just
they're unbridled trump hatred except
when joe and mika were visiting us a
couple days before the campaign in 2016
and we're all buddies then but now we're
not but
that's a whole other conversation but
the fact that they're they have to go
out there and essentially they hate
trump so they want to go and say this
isn't true they want to defend
themselves knowing that they spent
hundreds if not thousands of hours of
doing broadcasts saying russia russia
russia we're going to get this guy and
when you go into some of the especially
the hyperbole that we saw i mean look i
was a cnn commentator in 2017 and 2018
how many russia segments did i waste my
life doing on cnn uh and of course we
find out that it was all
uh two too many of these you know six on
one panels to you know to
to name
um
so here's the thing going forward we got
to make sure that the media is held
accountable that they don't get
completely snookered uh and taking down
these rabbit holes on future things
because as we saw from russia russia
russia i.e mueller impeachment one
impeachment two if trump runs again in
2024 which i think he does they're going
to have the next russia russia russia
they're going to have some next thing
that they come up with here is our
chance to finally beat the orange man uh
we're going to come up with some new
crackpot thing that the media all goes
running like lemmings uh they don't go
and actually do their own work they just
go out there and try to drive ratings
and and get clicks and we're going to
have the same thing happen again listen
it's it's uh
this line
what's the big deal
what's the big deal what's the big deal
with emails everybody does it what's the
big deal everybody does it what's the
big deals both sides uh
meddle in elections what's the big deal
no listen the big deal is that the
american people believe these guys can
get away with murder literally and if
you want to have people have trust in
the system there's got to be
accountability period left right middle
the part i was going to ask him with
barr
why why they didn't ask the question why
didn't they do the investigation he said
the only thing is i wish i would have
done this investigation earlier you were
taught my bar you know where i went to i
went to the area maybe they didn't want
to do the investigation because they
deep down and psyched out maybe there
was some kind of connection to russia do
you know what i'm saying i like the fear
for bar saying the internal voices the
the billboards
trump's camp we're like dude let's just
kind of not do because what if there is
and we don't you think they were
drinking some of the the the idol media
cool yeah i i don't know if they were or
not i'm not saying they were or not all
i'm saying is
it was such an effective campaign that
got his own side to believe it like
imagine if
everybody decides to go on a smear
campaign about you and we work together
right
and i've seen how you are for how many
years now three years of you know being
around each other i kind of know who you
are right
and they say and all of a sudden i'm
like yeah maybe he is like that maybe he
is this maybe he is that and i start
second guessing based on what i've
personally witnessed from you right and
i start buying into that the scary thing
is if trump's own camp started kind of
talking beyond closed doors saying maybe
this guy did something with russia would
he even tell us anyways if he did he
probably wouldn't tell us if he did you
know he's so much about wanting to win
so maybe bart didn't want to investigate
it i don't know again i i've never heard
i never heard any of that all the time
i'm not i'm not saying i'm right or
wrong only thing is
if you were so certain that something
was going on with spine why the hell
wouldn't you start earlier because i'm
gonna tell you because barr
is keep mine bar was attorney general
before uh in the final days there's a
beast uh yes he was attorney general
like 38 or 39 i wouldn't say so he's
been a he's a heavyweight we know he's
heavyweight and he's been around for a
long time there is a
for many people in washington who are
trump allies uh at least or were trump
allies where they might be there's this
push and pull of certain people really
over think and worry about other people
are to say about them are they going to
be allowed at the mclean country club
what's going to happen while i'm in uh
and
bar lives in mclean what happens when
i'm you know going to these events and
people see me at the parties are they
going to think that uh oh this guy's
unhinged or he did something
politically charged uh using his abused
his government power for a political
reason i think this was a he knew that
something stunk he knew something was
bad he didn't want it to happen 2020
become a campaign issue and he
overthought this one and actually guess
what it probably was a campaign issue
because if the spying went on into
trump's administration and he had to
waste multiple years of his
administration pushing back on these
russia rumors it most certainly was a
2020 issue
that's where i would just that's that's
my thought
and how much credibility do you think
john durham has
i mean he seems to be uh
i probably can't i just i don't know him
um i think that uh i my concern also too
is that the longer we get past trump
leaving office that people start to say
why are we going back to something in
the past to your point that you raise
like why does this matter now is this
okay put the one person but should we
really be making a big deal the longer
you get away from it the less like
likelihood there is of being true
accountability yeah i mean listen every
day for god knows how long everybody was
watching the oj trial case right okay
okay
how long did that last
how many times a day was it on tv how
many hours did it was until biggest
story so it was at 94 let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question
why
who cares so let's let's take your
position who cares whether he did or
let's just you know who cares if he did
how does that affect my life actually
think about it how did what oj did
to his ex-wife affect your life
think about that
well
but no actually think about it directly
directly
you probably want accountability so we
are more concerned about holding
citizens
accountable
than those who create laws and have
control of the u.s government that we
pay taxes to
and yeah it's okay year and a half
watching o.j every day of course we have
to do that but year and a half of trying
to catch the bad guy if there was any
manipulation behind this with the
government guys we just got to move on
we just got to move on because oj's
trial was way more important than
hillary clinton and this kind of stuff
no no to be clear i think that's why i
kind of get i know you're not you need
to have some accountability yeah but
does this move the needle moving i think
that's my only question no no forget
election i don't even think election
forget about the election it's got
nothing to do with election you know
what it's going to do here's what it's
going to do it's going to one
you know get the next guy that's
thinking about doing it to say
it ain't as easy as it used to be before
kind of kick back guys because the price
is that big
and number two what it's going to do is
it's going to get people to say okay you
know all these guys that have been
telling me that they're doing all this
stuff for me in my favor yeah you were
full of and i'm sorry my vote
matters a lot and the same way
barry goldwater what he did
he
when they went after him you know four
years later the african-american vote
went from 64 percent democrat to 92
democrat yeah that that that was a
consequence the price had to be paid and
the american people today have to know
because their vote matters today more
than ever before there's one other thing
i'd also put a kind of a finer point on
this i think
public trust in government institutions
is probably an all-time low right now i
know trust in certainly for congressman
that is definitely for congressman
aspects of federal law enforcement
and obviously there are all sorts of
concerns with elections and things like
that i think we need to make sure that
the public has confidence that all
aspects of law enforcement of national
security type agencies
that leaders who are in the white house
so they have that confidence of what
actually to what extent government power
is being abused uh to what extent the
people who are writing laws is this
gonna be allowed to happen again is this
all essentially just do we have people
throw in the towel and just say this
whole system is rigged
i think that's terrible for democracy
it's a big part of the reason why trump
won because people thought the whole
system was rigged and it was stacked
against people and
certainly you look at stagflation lack
of wage growth over the last couple of
decades and you'd say ever since nafta
and you say that's definitely the case
we have to do something here in the
country to restore some aspect of trust
and confidence because right now it's
terrible i mean look as someone who uh
you know grew up as kind of you know the
the g-men you know the fbi like these
these are the good guys i mean i mean
i've a number of people i went to
college with for example they went in
the fbi and you know they're always like
you know the fbi those are the good guys
like yeah like we're the ones who are
stopping the bad guys but now what's
happened over the last couple years with
the internal politics and seeing the
swirl um people have uh many people that
have a negative view of our law
enforcement uh or some of these these
government agencies and i think that's
terrible or even just the legal system
uh as a whole and and we got to restore
some of that trust yeah i think i think
uh
i had gordon chang gone
he lived in china for 20 some years
lawyer yeah and he says in 1980
something there was only four
law schools in china
and what what the law does it increases
trust that people cannot be bullied now
we all know i've paid
i don't know in the last 12 years 10
million dollars to legal fees not
because of lawsuits but because of
contract this contract that contract
this and every time you talk to a lawyer
for 10 minutes that was a two hour
conversation here's 1200 bucks so i have
my own opinions about lawyers but yeah
don't get me started
the legal system
allows you to walk outside and feel
safe
the legal system allows me to drive in
the streets safer
the legal system allows me to
have my kids go out and they're not
around me i'm not overly paranoid
because i trust the legal system there's
there's a certain
certain safety and security the legal
system brings to you right
they say many times women are with a man
they want to feel secure and safe right
when she sits next to you you feel safe
you're like okay there's a certain
safety that you're bringing to me okay
that's a role that we got to play many
times i think that's a legal system and
i think the importance about this is
the american people are going to say
okay there is law and order in america
that's all there is there is i've had
one too many speeding tickets i've
deserved every one of them my license
has been suspended a couple times i was
speeding i deserved it i'm not going to
sit and tell you i was and every time
the cop one time a cop pulls me over and
he says do you know how fast you were
going i said yeah much faster than you
couldn't catch out and he starts
laughing he says what is the matter with
you i said bro i got so many tickets man
what do you want to answer if you're
going to give it to me give it to me but
i'm just having fun with you says you
know what is he always like this and
jen's like i'm so sorry but he is he's
always like this you know what just can
you slow down and i'm like i slowed down
i'm so sorry i said just go and i left
never give me a ticket well you didn't
slow down no of course i didn't slow
down but i left but i did slow down for
five miles you have to you have to
respect accountability we gotta talk
about accountability i got pulled over
for this like two years ago for talking
on my cell phone right and and the
officer is like why were you on your
cell phone like i was talking to the
president
and he just looks at me he's like huh
it's like yeah i was talking to the
president he's like and then he kind of
paused for him and he's like why did you
use the bluetooth because it was cutting
out and i was like as a presence so i
had to like you know talk to him and
he's kind of paused i'm in arlington
virginia right so no i got the ticket
now that dude
yeah that didn't it didn't help at all
yeah i i probably could have said great
story what i should have said was like i
was on the phone with hillary clinton
yeah oh you know what oh sorry sir can i
escort you to your house you're gonna be
safe exactly sir i was organizing uh the
next black lives matter uh protest and
um you may have been safer especially
where you ran yeah i guaranteed myself
did he believe you
uh
of course you know okay buddy sure
you're talking to the president here's
the ticket
right now by the way did you hear about
what happened with the remington and
sandy hook you heard about that so let
me read this story pretty interesting
what happened here uh uh so
what story is it on number three
okay here we go so sanu family settled
with remington making first-time gun
maker held liable for mass shooting this
is abc news story remington arms agreed
tuesdays to settle liability claims from
the families of five adults and four
children killed in a massacre of san
diego elementary school according to a
new court filing marking the first time
a gun manufacturer had been held
accountable for mass shooting
in the u.s remington agreed to pay the
families
73 million
dollars
thoughts really
uh i'm worried about what this is going
to lead to for the the lawsuits against
the future lawsuits and settlements from
gun manufacturers um
this this could be the first step in
truly wiping out the second amendment
the united states i i get worried about
the the precedent that this why would
remington agree though
they must have they must have made the
calculation that if they go to the
courts and that they would lose even
bigger and but it's a
it's a slippery slope when you start
going down that uh down that path to
hold manufacturers accountable for um a
horrific uh horrific um murders of kids
um yeah but they didn't they just sold
it right because it says the families
argued remington negligently entrusted
to civilian consumers an assault rifle
that is assault style rifle that is
suitable for use only by military and
law enforcement personnel and violated
the connecticut
unfair trade practices act through the
sale or wrongful marketing of the rifle
well i think it's what's interesting is
they they they really jumped on the
marketing component they use the word
more so here's the deal
they said marketing weapons of war
directly to young people known to have
strong fascination with firearms is
reckless and too many families know
deadly con conduct using marketing
to convey that a person is more powerful
and more masculine by using a particular
type or brand of fire firearm is deeply
irresponsible and then that's what you
talked about the connecticut unfair
trade practices through the sale or
wrongful
marketing
of the rifle they keep using that term
but that's market let's use the word
marketing but then that means
you have to go
uh uh sue every movie that had a gun in
it that a kid watched you have to go
super good
for making gi joes yeah go go get 50 50
cents go go
uh go sue every rapper that talks about
cap you know that talks about
alzheimer's you know so why would
remington settle that's exactly the
question because if they went to court
they would have lost everything yeah
yeah but
you get jurors in there and it's it was
you're talking about kids that were
killed and so you get a jury together it
doesn't matter where in the country
people get really uncomfortable yeah
rightfully so when they they see
something perfectly like that but the
precedent that's being set here
i mean i saw that first thing i thought
was second amendment is cooked um
they're just they're gonna basically
wipe out domestic uh gun manufacturers
first of all what you do is if i'm sorry
go ahead finish yourself no yeah yeah
what i was going to say is
so you know
the good and the bad of lawyers
is many times you'll sue and just
because you're a headache somebody's
going to settle with you right but now
guess what every lawyer is doing
searching any shootings that's happened
the last five years 10 years and you're
calling and saying hey did you see what
remington just got let's go 30 i get you
get the rest if i get 50 million i get
15 million you get 35 million you up for
it let's go after them because they're
selling cases left and right
if this is a 73 million dollar case over
like seven years or whatever the amount
of timeline is that they're paying what
was it seven years eight years ten years
some number that they're paying
this is going to set the precedence for
this to happen many many more times
what i thought about on why they settled
is if
you did sell guns to an underage person
absolutely this has to be the case if
you did sell guns to somebody that you
didn't follow the background check of
that state yes absolutely but that's
that's not remington that's the dealer
of the arm is it not that's the best
yeah is it
and sold it directly is what i'm saying
but i thought it went through and i
apologize on this i thought it went
through a dealer it did no it did go
right so remington i mean okay so then
why isn't that dealer um the person who
actually sold it to him that would be if
someone
turned a blind eye if there was some
corner that was cut or something like
that's not the manufacturer well let me
use an analogy let's say you buy a ford
f-150 and you know some psychopath runs
over to escape in wisconsin sure yeah
and you
run over somebody in a parade whatever
is the is the manufacturer the to be
blamed
this is very slippery whereas 99.9
percent of people are just going to
drive their car and
not do that right or so because they're
not after the vehicle industry they're
after the gun industry i mean some
people might say that they are after the
oil industry
yeah but ford's already working to put
in electric vehicles i mean we're going
to have all electric vehicles in
california several other states by 2035.
i mean this is specifically targeted at
the gun industry and as jason said
they're trying to find loopholes to
completely wipe out the second amendment
this is the one area where i don't argue
with the families
i don't argue with the families one of
the kids name is a name i like a lot
okay
i don't argue with the families i don't
even want to
wish this upon my own enemies for this
to become a reality so for them
yeah you have everything to you in that
mindset of a parent totally get it i
fully understand it at all costs for
anything that took your kid away yes
fully understand the
anger the rage one million percent
set that part aside the other side is if
the strategy was ever to go after second
amendment this is a brilliant strategy
to do because it's going to scare the
crap out of every gun maker out there if
you're a gun maker i mean you're
basically looking right now saying
i don't even know how we can be
domiciled in the u.s yeah we're cooked i
mean that business is now cooked because
it doesn't matter if it's remington or
cole or smith wesson or anyone else
domestic
gun manufacturers they have the targets
on them now let me ask this about aoc
let's transition into texas because
obviously when you think guns you think
texas you think about a lot of that but
aoc says it's inevitable that texas will
turn blue this is an insider story okay
aoc made the claim saturday during the
campaign style for progressive
candidates jessica cisneros and greg
sasad uh casa casa is running for
primaries for texas 35 35th
congressional district against
democratic lawmaker lloyd dogett
cisneros is running in the state 28
congressional district against another
democratic lawmaker representative henry
sulad here's what's exciting about
jessica's race and greg's race is that
if we flip texas we flip the country
texas turning blue is inevitable
inevitable it will happen the only
question is when said aoc we are going
to fight for a living wage as a minimum
wage we're going to make sure we
unionize the hell out of the state we're
going to make sure that we confront
corrupt industries and lobbyists and big
money said aoc will that ever happen
in texas not not in the way that she's
thinking for a simple fact that i think
democrats as i said earlier have done
such damage to themselves with latino
and hispanic american communities uh i
mean i'm old enough to remember 20 years
ago when people said that florida was
going to go blue it would never come
back look at the diversity that we have
in florida look we have all these uh
people from central and south american
countries people come from africa and
other countries from all over the world
there's no way that's going to just stay
this this red state well guess what uh
many of the people who are coming to
florida support freedom they support
democracy who are people to your point
earlier about laws and you know one who
really respects laws in america
immigrants why because in some of the
countries where they came from they
didn't have the rule of law that was
something that maybe they had in america
so the success story that you've seen
with um
latinos and hispanic americans in
florida i think also the damage
democrats have done in texas will make
it tougher now obviously they're not
monolithic community so it's that we
have not had the same movement
we haven't had quite the same movement
with say mexican-americans we have would
say cuban-americans but i think uh aoc's
uh taking a little uh too much of a
tunnel vision on this one i don't think
it's quite accurate could at some point
a democrat win in the state of texas uh
look i mean you can never say like never
that's indefinitely the rest of it but
do i think that the state's ultimately
going to try to become blue not
necessarily not with the way that
democrats have turned a blind eye but it
has been trending
no doubt but
what has changed and trends are tough to
break but what has changed the trend
is the democrats embrace of blm and you
look at that rio grande valley seat uh
that flipped there was a very strongly
uh uh democratic seat that we won uh
along with trump in 2020 here's the
thing i was on the phone yesterday with
um along with president trump we were
talking to someone who we'll just say
they're high up in uh uh congressional
stuff and we're talking to them about
texas there's a seat there's a democrat
plus ten district plus ten usually like
in the three to five range even on a
good year maybe it's in play maybe if
there's a kind of a tidal wave d
plus 10
that republicans are targeting and the
reason being because they think the
hispanics are going to flip so much
against biden and against the democrats
that it's actually in play
that dynamic but what i don't know is
how much of that is kind of the the city
is that in
[Music]
the answer they don't remember the exact
words if you look at the map of texas
you look at any major city that they
voted dallas houston san antonio
well adam look at look at this bottom
right here on the map on the tv it's all
blue right and what is that right up
against it's up against the border we're
having we're gonna have two plus million
immigrants come into the country this
year alone imagine this keeps going
hispanics do not like
hispanics that live here don't like the
illegal immigration because they know
what it does to their jobs they know
what it does to their wages etc etc when
is that map from this is from 2020 this
is this is before the immigration this
could it'll be interesting to see what
happens in 2022.
that's a lot of red right there but
we'll see but look at the popular vote i
mean it's it's neck and neck it's it's
eight six percentage points yeah i mean
even when beto went against ted i
watched that debate i mean i was a close
call between those two guys you know and
and
ted should have lapped the guy yeah but
it's and beto just flipped his stance on
guns on second amendment because he he
understood that it was close he thinks
he can win texas they think they can
flip texas but 2022 texas is going to be
about whether he's going to yeah
you can never say never but in the short
term at least the next two four years uh
i i don't see it moving as fast as aoc
would like i think aoc maybe
she probably has better success in south
florida uh she likes south florida she
likes hanging out she likes that foreign
a lot a lot and she would agree if uh
texas flips that's that really hurts
republicans chances as well oh yeah i
mean yes there's a no small little oh
well you might but it's not facts as
you're finished it's not in a in a
vacuum you look at the way that uh say
wisconsin michigan pennsylvania have all
shifted further to the right in the last
two presidential races uh those those
have not been contested states in some
20 25 years and now they're viewed as
toss-ups blue wall that uh
florida got two more republican by the
way just so you know florida went up two
more republican which means the florida
state matters more now than it did a
year ago two years ago three years ago
four years ago it's going in the
direction of those who like to be free
those who like to have jobs those who
like to pay low taxes those who like to
be left alone those who like
uh crypto with the guys we had at the
house yesterday to god knows one time
talking about meta and nfts and all
these different things
florida's uh florida's got some good
strategies good things going for
themselves i just hope texas fights
to keep that going because i think
i want to say 50
or 52
of fortune 500 companies headquarters is
in that state that's a lot of states the
only one beating them
is new york city new york's the only
state that has more fortune 500
companies headquarters than it does
there i think silicon valley is
competing for that as well with texas
anyways jason this has been a blast
thank you so much for coming out uh can
you do me a favor put the link together
below for people that want to learn more
about getter uh put it both in the
comments section as well as in the chat
section so people can go check it out
for themselves and maybe join and see
you know experience it for yourself and
uh we'll go from there jason again
thanks for coming out buddy appreciate
you take care
you